the risk of travel almost two years into
covid keeps changing just as countries
started opening borders to international
travelers a new coronavirus strain has
triggered a whole new set of travel
restrictions
clint henderson is senior news editor
with the point sky and is here now to
help us navigate these changes and
provide us some tips for those who are
planning to venture away from home
whether near or far clint welcome back
to quick take you have done a fantastic
job compiling a very handy 70 000 word
guide on the pointsguy.com laying out
the maze of rules that travelers have to
negotiate before setting off but let's
just take a step back here and start at
the beginning
assume that i have not set foot on a
plane since march 2020 where do i start
what do i need how much more expensive
should i expect my trip to be
so if you're traveling internationally
it's is where it gets complicated so
for say you haven't taken any flights at
all if you're flying domestically
there's really nothing to worry about
hawaii is the one exception to that so
they have some special rules but other
than that domestic travel you're good to
go pretty much
international travel gets really tricky
so you now need a negative covet test
within one day of your flight to return
to the united states now that used to be
three days if you were vaccinated that
has gone away as omicron has spread and
governments have sort of panicked about
this new variant
they've tightened restrictions even
further so you need a covert test within
one day of your departure back to the
united states now that's not 24 hours so
you have a full day before your trip to
get that test so it's not the end of the
world
most resorts most hotels around the
world are now very aware of the rules
they will help you they will guide you
they'll tell you to tell you where to
get tested you can have testing people
come to your hotel room there are some
resorts that have testing centers on
property so i have traveled some
internationally the past couple months
it gets complicated but once you sort of
know the basics you'll generally be okay
okay got it so you'll need to get tested
before you leave you might need to get
tested when you arrive as well
that being the case everyone getting
tested before they leave potentially
once they arrive does being vaccinated
matter at this point at all if everyone
needs to get tested one way or another
so at the point scale we say everyone
should get tested everyone should get
boosters where available because that's
the only way we're going to get this
virus in check but i will say
that it depends on the country so if
you're vaccinated some countries are
throwing open their arms and they say
come on in but the rules are changing
day to day and that's why keeping up
with every uh country's requirement has
been such a beast to do on the site but
we do update that every week so if you
are curious about a specific country you
can go to the points guy search for our
country by country guide and we have
every single country laid out for you
colombia was one example where they made
it so easy for vaccinated americans to
come now they've suddenly changed what
they're requiring and they're going to
require a test even if you're vaccinated
so it gets complicated but there are
sites there are uh sources
for you to keep up with those changing
work okay so it's a very fluid situation
i just wonder how much coordination
there is
at the top of the government and here
i'm talking about each country for
instance the philippines tourism board
recently made an online video basically
embracing kovid and all the safety
protocols they put in place uh just
letting people know tourists know that
they've got it covered and that if you
come you'll be in good shape you'll be
in good hands because we know what we
need to do to keep you safe
they kind of call this the new normal
how
how effective is this kind of
advertising does this put people's minds
at ease and and encourage tourism to a
place like the philippines
i think it does i think you know some
countries have been better than others
at sort of like rolling out the red
carpet and saying we got your back you
know we're going to take care of you god
forbid you you know test positive why
you're here we're going to put you up in
a hotel and we're going to pay for it
other countries are like basically
saying to travelers you're on your own
uh you know i i think the general advice
is
pick a country where you
are pretty sure that you're going to be
taken care of once you get there
you know mexico has been great it's uh
it's been sort of the wild west
very few rules but at the same time all
the resorts in cancun have testing sites
available so those resorts you know if
you get an all-inclusive resort in
places like mexico you know you know
that the hotel is going to make sure you
have what you need to get back home i
will say the airlines have gotten really
good since they've been the enforcers uh
the airlines are now rolling out apps of
their own to help you do a checklist
before you leave
and make sure you have all your
documents uploaded so i imagine things
will get easier as we go through the
pandemic we've had two years
it's still a little catches catch can
but i think it is getting better well
airlines are being really good about it
because they want your business and in
many cases they want someone else's
business as well united and delta for
instance were still flying to south
africa when omicon was first
when it first happened and they were
basically taking away business from the
european carriers and the gulf carriers
my producer was saying that people were
flying from cape town to
london via newark because there was no
other flight available they just
couldn't get to where they wanted to go
otherwise um how much do you see that as
the airlines just trying to siphon each
other off
siphon customers off each other
yeah i mean it's smart if you're an
airline you want to be ultra competitive
uh
when it comes to covet safety though i
think most airlines are being extremely
cautious i think as the weeks have gone
on since we first discovered omicron
it's not quite as
big a threat as we at first suppose so
uh i think it ended up being a smart
strategy on the part of delta and united
to keep those flights going but remember
if you're an american you're going to be
able to get home america is not telling
american citizens they can't come home
there's just added hoops you have to
jump through at this point got it got it
what are you seeing when it comes to
people and their holiday travel plans
because omicron began spreading right as
people were gearing up for their holiday
travel plans do you see people changing
perhaps what was going to be a long-haul
trip to something closer and you know
maybe near home
yes absolutely so we've seen anecdotal
evidence of people canceling
international trips and and saying you
know what i'm just going to go to
charleston because
i want to stay closer to home i don't
want to risk being stuck overseas
the risk doesn't seem to be as extreme
as we thought a couple weeks ago
so i'm not sure how long that dip in
traffic but the airlines did say they
saw a decline in bookings especially for
international flights we also saw search
volume uh drop for international
bookings so uh domestically it does not
seem to be having much of an impact but
i think you know international travel
was already struggling around 30 percent
is all it's recovered so far since
before the pandemic and uh this is not
going to help international travel
that's for sure no it certainly doesn't
let's just say that you did have plans
uh flight plans and you wanted to change
them are the airlines still being fairly
flexible and understanding when it comes
to rescheduling are they charging you
are they nickel and diming you for
change fees and all of that
so we've seen a revolution in how
airlines are treating leisure travelers
uh leisure travelers are in the driver's
seat for the most part and have been
since the pandemic started airlines have
thrown out change fees uh they've a lot
of times will give you a refund maybe
not cash anymore like they were doing
we're doing in the height of the
pandemic but they will give you a
voucher for future travel so you can
book with more confidence now uh so that
even if a catastrophe happens and you
need to change or cancel that booking
the airlines are being much more
flexible and i say to people all the
time call the airlines just work with
them tell them your situation tell them
you're uncomfortable flying you might be
even be able to get a full cash refund
even though that's not policy but you
can't even get through to the airline i
mean if you try calling them you're on
hold for five hours
well sometimes they the whole times have
been bad because they don't have enough
workers but it's gotten better and delta
and other airlines now have automated
systems that will call you back so you
don't have to sit there on hold but yeah
you're right during peak times if
there's any kind of weather issue or you
know there's a uh
sort of service outage then you can't
expect extremely long hold times here's
another trick for you try using twitter
direct messenger uh that works wonders
american airlines is excellent at
responding alaska airlines is excellent
responding uh via via twitter direct
message so try that trick and some of
the airlines are even doing direct
texting now so there is uh workarounds
out there uh go to the points guy we've
got all the hacks for you there great
tips okay so once the year-end holiday
season passes um you kind of have a
quiet period for a while and then things
start up again because a lot of people
travel during february when some schools
are out and people want to get away to
somewhere warmer what warm locales are
most inviting right now in terms of
there aren't a lot of restrictions the
it's low maintenance in terms of getting
there and and staying there and being
safe
so a lot of americans are obviously
choosing florida we have in fact see
more traffic to florida now than we did
pre-pandemic which is remarkable you
think about it spirit is adding flights
allegiance adding flights american delta
everyone's going to florida now so
you're seeing florida being very popular
with americans but also mexico cancun i
think is like the top one of the top
five cities in the world now for foreign
visitors uh because mexico has made it
fairly easy to visit uh so i would say
mexico florida and lots of places in the
caribbean have rolled out the red carpet
are making it easier for americans to
visit we expect those trends to continue
uh through the winter and into 2022. got
it okay clint uh last word for you here
what is the number one tip you have for
people who are getting ready to travel
for the holiday season but haven't yet
made their plans
so one of my favorite tricks is pack
your patience that's number one we
always say the points guy but also
get clear or tsa pre-check to speed you
through the lines a lot of credit cards
give it to you free when you sign up for
the credit card and it has saved me so
much time it also prevents me from
having to deal with huge crowds at tsa
lines so that's my number one hack
fantastic clint really appreciate your
joining us clint henderson is senior
news editor at the point sky thank you
so much